[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh
[Music]
there we go
you gotta dig
is it cold out here
yeah it's really cold and the
temperatures are only going to get
colder should we go camping
so cold all the plastic is frozen
hopefully nothing breaks
you have to kind of insert the pole the
elastic's not very stretchy at this
temperature
all right got step one done i better get
this thing off and going
whoa
oh my lips are getting numb it's hard to
stalk
the tarps so frozen and crinkled it's
too small to fit in all the grommets i'm
having a yank on it for all my worth to
get it to stretch
and go where it's supposed to go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
we got heat
thank goodness well it's four o'clock
and we're already busting out the
flashlights
[Music]
just sit down right oh
here nice now i want you to sit down
right over here is that warm
[Music]
here we go
there you go buddy can sit back there
there we go
we were really slow getting started this
morning it took us a lot longer to get
here than i anticipated
and it's already dark it's 4 30
and it is bitterly cold but we got the
tent out with the stove on
jacob's warm
finally we're doing okay
all right let's get in and get buttoned
down for the night
all right got a caribou hide down here
on the grounds can take my boots off
oh that really helps
another hide to sleep on
oh yeah i take some
layers off it's hot in here
oh well jake what do you think are you
warm
good let's get our sleeping bags out
i'll let the sleeping bags puff up
i'm gonna put a thermometer up here so
we can see
how warm it gets in the tent
and i've got another thermometer i'm
gonna put outside
oh look at my arm
my arm is steaming
[Music]
that's
[Music]
right let that melt get some hot water
going
up here
the very top of the tent
it's 98 degrees the heat from the stove
rises and collects at the top of the
tent so there's real extreme
temperature differences in here my
head's kind of sweaty
but my feet are kind of numb let's put
the thermometer down here and i'll show
you the difference so check it out here
on the floor it's right around freezing
at 32 degrees
i have another thermometer here on the
bed you can see that this one's at 60
degrees so that makes a huge difference
in temperature just being off the floor
a little bit every inch off the ground
you get in a hot tent the warmer you're
gonna be
that's why you use cots in these things
it makes a huge difference to being a
cot versus on the ground
thermometer says we're right about
negative 40. it is cold out here guys
and it's only gonna get colder tonight
oh my goodness i went outside for just a
few minutes without my balaclava on and
my ears hurt so bad
oh it happened so quick it's a 138
degree difference between outside and
inside
it's a little early for full-blown
dinner so we're going to have pre-dinner
and we're going to do a traditional
swiss camping food called rock-alette
rocklet raclette rocklet braclet
okay it's pronounced raclette but
basically it's broiled cheese on
potatoes and bread you can use roclette
or gruyere or maybe even gouda
all the frost on my knife
still cuts
i'd put some olive oil and salt on some
potatoes here
we got the cheese potatoes and breads
underneath the stove let's see what
happens
look at that oh that smells amazing
bread is just perfectly toasted
oh
that tastes so good
this is basically a fancy pantsy swish
grilled cheese sandwich that's so good
that is so warm and tasty
this recline is so good i almost forgot
i got some salami to go with it
oh yeah
it is so nice and warm in here but the
ground is so cold my toes are frozen
this feels nice
oh ho
negative 51.
oh man
much much warmer in here
it is so cold out there and so nice in
here
you want some hot chocolate yeah
yeah all right i'll get you some hot
chocolate
so this thing right here is a water tank
you put a bunch of snow in here or water
whatever and uh it heats up against the
side of the stove and then you can just
turn this
get hot water whenever you want it you
gotta admit that's awesome it really is
oh
[Music]
we already got some diced onions and
olive oil
[Music]
there we go we're going to add some cut
up reindeer sausage here
[Music]
are you getting too hot yeah okay here
let's take your jacket off
let's uh
open the window a little bit and we can
go and shut the flue a little bit
this tent is made by arctic oven and the
model is called the igloo and i've heard
people claim it's the warmest hot tent
in the world
and i think they're right i mean it's
negative 51 outside and we're having to
open the window and shut the flu on the
stove box a little bit i think the only
way i can improve this tent is to have a
battery powered fan on the roof to blow
the hot air down and maybe more
insulation on the floor that's about it
i got the boiling bag rice i'm gonna
start cooking that up and uh we're gonna
have curry here a little bit all right
[Music]
we got some mango curry sauce we're
gonna add to our reindeer and onions
this might be the first mango reindeer
curry ever made
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
bread's cold
i heat that up
we got reindeer mango curry
you want to try some of that bud
you like
that oh that is good
you need to use a potty
okay let's get out and pee buddy it's
gonna be cold
there you go got your balaclava
all right come on out that's crazy you
go p and your p just starts freezing
immediately there's like this little p
snow that kind of dusts off it
all right let's get back in
looks like we've gotten down to about
negative 55.
all right oh yeah here get it
here hop in buddy
get get back in i'm a pretty lucky dad
to have such a sweet boy comes camping
with
me may have bribed him with a lot of hot
chocolate and cartoons but i'm still
grateful that he came
i'm gonna pull out jake's sleeping bag
here let it fluff up and warm up this is
the snowy owl from feathered friends
it's a negative 60 bag it's as far as i
can tell the warmest sleeping bag in the
world and feathered friends will even
customize the length for you so i had
them shorten it quite a bit
so it'll fit the boys
these are real serious sleeping bags and
that's what you want in this situation
because when i go to sleep this fire is
going to die down and i may not wake up
in time to stoke it so if you have
really good bags then you're not going
to have to wake up as much to stoke the
fire if you have crappy bags you're
gonna be waking up every hour to two
hours to feed the fire it's it's kind of
miserable
we had a lovely dinner but we've got a
lot of leftover rice so i think i'm
gonna make a little bit of dessert do
you want some rice pudding
all right i got some milk with a little
bit of vanilla extract in it and i've
got all the spices in this bag it's
basically sugar cinnamon nutmeg some
fennel seed a little bit of salt and
lots of raisins
basically we're going to boil that
mixture until about eighty percent of
the rice is broken down then we're gonna
add a little bit of butter and we're
gonna crack an egg in it and it's gonna
be rice pudding rice pudding's looking
pretty good
[Music]
all right
let that cool down a little bit and then
we'll have some beautiful rice pudding
all righty
that looks chilled
hey the rice pudding looks pretty good
might be a few splinters in it and
definitely a few caribou hairs but other
than that it's good
i do like rice pudding
do you like it
yeah i'll tell you guys
what do you want to do next what's your
mouse
i need to get a marshmallow stick and
it's going to be cold
that looks like negative 57 to me maybe
dang it
it is serious
so brittle it just snapped
yeah this is a this is a green switch
look at that
oh it is so cold out there i i breathed
in and it like it was making me cough
that is no joke out there
[Music]
is that good
yeah
nobody it's late i think we need to get
you to bed you look tired you got
marshmallow on your face look at all
this
you tucked in there you warm
good all right good night
jacob jacob's asleep and i'm getting
ready for bed
i gotta go get a bunch more kindling and
tinder
if the fire goes out in the middle of
the night and we're freezing we need to
be able to start it again really quick
without getting out of bed
i've got all my logs cut and split and
some kindling my fire starting equipment
all within arm's reach so i can get the
fire stoked up or restarted without
having to get out of my bag another
thing i did is i put a little bit of
rope around jacob's sleeping bag his bag
is so puffy i'm worried about him
getting too close to the edge and maybe
melting a hole in it or something what i
really need is a piece of chicken wire
that i can just wrap around the stove
to keep people from accidentally bumping
into it when they're asleep but uh i
think this will do for right now
that fire is
roaring i'm gonna turn that down a
little bit
there we go calm the fire down a little
bit i'm just gonna kind of hunker down
for the rest of the night we've got
about 12 hours before the sun comes up
so uh we're just gonna kind of take it
easy i'm gonna read a book a little bit
get to bed and
just enjoy a quiet warm night hopefully
i just stepped outside to use the
bathroom before going to bed
and thermometer says
negative 58.
oh
oh it's cold i think i get back in
oh
oh i stepped outside for one minute and
it feels like i'll never be warm again
i'm going to bed guys i'll see you in
the morning
take you up
had a little bit of a fitful night's
sleep
i was just worried about jacob make sure
he was okay and so i was checking on him
throughout the night and ended up
stoking the fire pretty regularly still
managed to get some decent sleep and man
these sleeping bags are warm though i
really had nothing to worry about me and
jake both woke up too hot not in the
middle of the night at some point but
it's about 9 00 a.m and i'm gonna get
the fire cranked up then we're gonna get
up make some breakfast sun will be up in
about hour and a half
look at this
got a little cold last night on the
floor of the tent uh the milk with the
vanilla extract in it froze
yeah so did the curry
that's why you leave your water bottle
next to the stove
i was planning on doing some fun
demonstrations to show you how cold it
is outside so i brought a thing of
little blowing bubbles
unfortunately i left it too close to the
door and now it is
it is hard as a rock hopefully we can
thaw it out
[Music]
there we go that looks pretty good
oh that needle is buried
that looks like negative 59 to me
you take like one breath and your
boogers just like
freeze up
oh it's hard on the lungs i'm gonna take
a load of stuff back to the car
and i'm gonna go make sure the car
starts it's so cold i'm really worried
about the car starting
all right let's see if it'll start
moment of truth here
oh that was sketchier than i thought you
know a lot of times when you watch these
videos you get the impression that i
just run out and go camping and really
there's a lot of safety stuff that goes
on in the background to make sure i can
do this with my kids safely i had to get
this car specifically for this trip this
car has been winterized and fluid's
changed a new battery all this stuff
specifically for extreme winter
temperatures if i had done this by
normal car probably wouldn't have
started we'd be stranded at negative 59.
in addition to the car i've got a
satellite phone my wife knows where i am
when i'm supposed to check in and what
to do if i don't and i've got people on
standby who can come and pick us up if
something happens to the car it is so
easy for equipment to break down at this
temperature and when it does you have
minutes before you start losing the tips
of your ears and your fingertips the
cold's really hard on my lights and my
video equipment i have to have special
cold weather batteries and when i'm not
filming i have to put the camera under
my armpit inside my jacket to keep it
from freezing
and even with that i usually get about
five ten minutes of filming per battery
all right looks like we thought out our
bubbles uh let's go and see what happens
when we blow some slightly warm bubbles
out there
we're gonna try to blow some bubbles
here at negative 59 degrees check this
out
it just exploded into snow
it froze
oh that is so cool
oh look at this
oh
it's so hard to film this but the
bubbles they go up in the air and within
two three seconds they freeze and you
can watch them crystallize and freeze
and then they kind of like deflate a
little bit
look at this
it's just like deflating it's hard to
catch them on the wand because the wand
is warm and it melts them
but that that was cool
all right now we're going to try boiling
water
oh that made the coolest hissing sound
it's like made little bits of fine snow
or mist
just hanging in the air
oh dang
man that is so close to negative 60. it
is bottomed out this thermometer
oh it is cold guys
i was just out there for a few minutes
and i am just cold
it is really aggressive out there it is
so cold out there i cannot dawdle and
film while i'm trying to put stuff away
so i'm gonna go put the camera down and
i'm gonna start packing up all of our
stuff and get into the car here i'm
gonna go ahead and take up as much stuff
as i can before i take the fire and put
it out
and get it out to the car i'm gonna make
sure the car is nice and warm before i
put this fire out
as good as you can
all right guys we're at that point where
i gotta put the fire out once i do it's
a race against time to get everything
put away before my fingers and feet
freeze
oh my lips are going numb
all right i'm gonna put the camera down
and do this thing
[Applause]
uh
all right
oh
all right now that we're loaded up we're
gonna see if i can
four by four my way out of here in
reverse
[Applause]
the car is so bumpy right now because
the tires are flat
the part that was resting on the ground
is frozen flat and you gotta drive a
little bit and warm up the tires before
they'll go around again
oh
oh my toes are so cold yeah these cars
are not good insulators and the problem
with driving in this extreme cold is
even with the foot heater on full blast
my feet are freezing in my negative 40
boots i've got to like stop pull over
and like warm up my my toes this is a
jug of water i had on the floorboard of
the car
it is frozen solid
luckily jacob's got little legs so his
feet are off the ground and warm your
feet warm
my feet are warming up i think we can do
this
i hope you guys all snuggled up at home
are warm and enjoying this video if you
want to see more great camping adventure
videos from the outdoor boys youtube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every saturday
morning
and check out our camping adventure
playlist with over 50 extreme camping
adventures with me and my sons
great times i'll put links in the video
description below but i go inside and
warm up my lip it's getting really hard
to talk to the camera again
all right guys
see you next saturday
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]